[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 57 all
the weekly Google+ on podcast I am
Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mendel hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good happy new year happy
New Year to you and to you all people
listening everywhere around the world
yeah and we're back again for 2017 and
we're back again with some incredibly
amazing episode I know that you're very
that's pretty cool we're talking to
edward woo
from Niantic about Pokemon go in this
episode yeah it's pretty exciting a
quick question are you more excited
about this episode or the episode with
John Wilkes so I feel like you can't
compare to your mom I think you can they
are both unique and wonderful in their
own ways yeah I'm very very excited
about this episode too there's so much
to learn about the whole experience that
they went through so yeah and we we're
gonna discuss all the interesting things
that they went through all the pokemons
that were cut and stuff like that yup
and then once we're done with that we
have a question of the week about
encryption keys yeah and which is pretty
cool cuz actually the answer is related
to something near to so very interesting
question in answer but before that we
have the cool things of the week the
first cool things of the week and we had
to choose only three out of the many
many many things that happen during the
during the holidays but we will spend
our time the future weeks basically
coming over all the cool thing it
doesn't I don't understand you figure
that people shut down over that period
but no apparently there's like let's
release a whole bunch of stuff they work
harder yeah please people chill
anyway so the first one is these blog
posts that was that he's part of the
Google cloud platform blog post on how
we secure our infrastructure as in how
we secure our own Google cloud platform
infrastructure so the the blog post is a
pretty short blog post but it actually
points to a security design white paper
that is definitely worth reading
it has I really like that starts with
the CIO level summary so there's
basically the four points that you care
about on what they're gonna be talking
about but you can go into it in more
details and see how we protect you
against like the do s attacks or how
encryption arrest works and how deletion
of data happens this is like so much
stuff there's all of those security
layers and they eat goes into detail on
every single one of them so it's
definitely worth as a curiosity really
yeah but if you are interested in
security it's definitely a good paper to
read actually it's worth noting really
this is like the beginning of a series
of stuff around security and identity
that are going to be happening on the
blog so it's definitely stay tuned
that's your thing and you're really
concerned about security and identity
yeah and if you not not gonna turn up a
security you should know now it's a very
interesting but uh white paper
nonetheless absolutely so the next one
is uh I don't know why this this just
makes me really happy I know a lot of
people wonder this for a while we now
have like actual icons and simple
architectural diagrams for designing
stuff like when you're building at your
architecture on Google cloud platform
and you want to design it out using
either say Google slides or lucidchart
or PowerPoint or you just need PNG s or
SVG s to put inside your favorite
diagramming software yeah we have those
now available to you so you can use them
which i think is actually really handy
I'm incredibly excited about it because
I like it is sad to say but very often I
would Google I would search on Google
for our own products to find that
exactly just you know our
representations I'm very happy that we
finally got a repository and it is open
so anyone can use it so if you think
about talking about how you use Google
cloud platform on a presentation feel
free to go and use them definitely now
we have one more yeah one more cool
thing of the week and this one is really
cool to start with because of course
it's raining out but also because it is
about something that many people have
asked me about how to do it which is how
do you do continuous deployment to
Google cloud platform specifically how
do you do continuous deployment to App
Engine
and container engine and turns out the
New York Times they have been using
Google cloud platform for quite a while
they had this issue and they solved it
and the open source project yeah it's
very cool there is a there's new sorry
there's an open source continuous
integration continuous deployment
platform called drone that's written in
go and they built plug-ins for it for G
ke and GAE so you can do continuous
delivery and deployment to those two
platforms yeah it's pretty cool it's all
built around containers containers we
all love containers and it's pretty neat
so super happy to see like the community
and the ecosystem around Google cloud
platform continue to grow yeah it is
it is definitely worth it so check it
out we have a link on the show nuts to
the blog post but also to the github
repos you can go and read the code
directly which is very nice cool well
why don't we go talk to eg what are we
gonna talk to Ed about up whoo come on
go sounds good better than so today I am
very excited to have Edward Wu here from
Niantic joining us on the podcast Edie
how are you doing today
very good thank you very much for having
me here I'm really excited to be able to
talk about how the past few ones have
gone yeah it's not like you've been up
to anything special exciting or anything
like that that anyone would have ever
heard of there's nothing big nothing
getting plenty of sleep of course yes of
course an excellent cool serve before we
go into the the magic of Pokemon go do
you want to tell us a little bit about
you and who you are and what you do sure
I'm a director of software engineering
here at the antic I actually lead the
Pokemon go engineering team done so
since we spun out of Google in October
of 2015 and all the way through the
launch of Pokemon go in last summer all
the way through today and in addition to
managing the engineering Apple
Initiative Pokemon go
I also product manager portions of our
technology platform which I'd be happy
to speak about later cool
so I heard something that surprised me
listening to one of my favorite podcast
which is not this one 99% invisible I
heard about this
ship below them Baca they are here in
San Francisco called the Niantic mmm
is there any relationship yeah that's
kind of what what our company is named
after and what our autonomous unit while
we were inside Google was named after
there's a ship that actually ran aground
they ran aground during the goldrush era
of San Francisco people were so excited
to get on shore that they decided just
to run it on ground and turn it into a
hotel rather than then continuing to
sail it back and forth and I think
though the sense of adventure and
discovery is is part of which what our
CEO and founder John was trying to evoke
there so you you mentioned just a bit
there like Niantic spun out of Google do
you want to give us a little background
of Niantic the company I think it's got
kind of a little unique history yeah
it's got a really unique history so our
CEO and CTO our CEO John Hanke and our
CTO Phil Kessel on are actually veterans
of previous startup that was acquired by
Google called keyhole keyhole made a
product which turned into what most
people know as Google Earth today and so
while they were in Google they were this
was the age when you know the first very
first set of smartphones began began to
go into the market so things that the
Google's Nexus One phone and they looked
at these things and they saw that the
majority of kind of entertainment and
experiences on them what are things like
Angry Birds which was novel from like an
input perspective was not particularly
making full use of the insane
capabilities that having a computer
carry around in your pocket could
provide right these things are you know
loaded with location sensors and network
capabilities in advanced processing
power they really thought there was
something that they could do to make
unique experiences for with with these
devices um that since they were portable
actually got people outside got people
to meet each other got people to explore
their world got people more engaged with
their communities they started
investigating a variety of product ideas
which could actually go towards that
goal and they came up with to which they
are both were quite informative both
from our product and technology
perspective for what eventually would
become Pokemon go so while we're in
Google we launched two products one is
called a field trip which uses the
location sensors on your phone to make
local recomm
Dacians of really interesting sites that
might be around might be around even
that you might want to check out another
was a game called ingress which is
something that if you play pokemon go
and then go back to you'll recognize
large elements there you know there's a
resource collection of a mechanic on the
move there are points of interest in the
game that the game tries to drive you
towards so interesting local historical
monuments or art or small interesting
local businesses and this game just like
pokemon go is a location-based game that
tries to actually get people to interact
out in the real world together
using a single consistent game game
board and so we were actually quite
successful in getting a lot of attention
on ingress and one of that bits of
attention was actually the folks at the
Pokemon company who saw that this game
that was actually getting people out
into the real world that was actually
getting them to meet others and explore
their local communities I was actually
kind of perfect fitnah matically for the
way that that Pokemon has been
throughout its entire IP IP lifetime and
so we were we decided to spin out of
Google as an independent company with a
with partnering with um Nintendo in the
Pokemon company to create Pokemon go yes
so you said that we've Niantic you got a
little bit of attention I'd say that
with Pokemon girl you got a little bit
of attention too it's kind of a big deal
could you give us a little bit an idea
of how big of a deal it was like we've
heard everyone saying it was it was huge
how huge was it yeah so as of December I
crunched these statistics every so often
with the help of that the engineering
team here we take a look at you know not
only the kind of more technical numbers
but some some product different ones so
we've actually had people walk more than
eight point seven billion kilometres
which for a sense of scale is past Pluto
and I think it's about two hundred
thousand times around the earth had
we've had 88 more than eighty eight
billion Pokemon caught by our players
collectively so just to give you this
your sense of scale I mean it's almost
beyond comprehension
you know the collective effort that
people were put into not only playing
this game but actually when you think
about all that walking's the exercise
and exploration and you know meeting of
new people that that that they've done
in the midst of it from a more technical
perspective you know the Senate to give
you an idea of you know how much bigger
this was then then what we expected it
was roughly 50 times greater than the
capacity the capacity that we actually
had planned for at launch of EPs
actually a story and be happy to go into
because it was it goes to the heart of
why the Google Cloud team was there such
an instrumental part of our success so
before we go into more details I had a
quick question about those 88 billion
Pokemon card how many of them were
pitches people people play the game for
different reasons right I think some
people go and they try to catch every
Pidgey in sight because it gets them
some Stardust which would allow them to
park their other Pokemon other people um
you know try to pick and choose so I
don't think the the distribution that
you see on the screen is not necessarily
the distribution that people actually
end up end up catching okay intersects
it alright so yeah let's let's get stuck
into the technical side of these because
I think this is absolutely fascinating
you mentioned as well they obviously if
you played ingress before you can see
elements of that yeah in Pokemon go did
you end up using the same stuff that you
use the same products that you used in
ingress or did you take lessons learnt
from ingress and change certain things
like what what was different between the
two products and like what what what
lessons did you learn between them from
a technical architectural standpoint the
major transition that we made was from
App Engine which was a previous
generation of Google's cloud computing
products to Google container engine
which was something that only came out
of a few years - after ingress had
started and so we had taken we did take
the opportunity to modernize some of our
technical infrastructure be happy to go
a bit into that later but many of the
core algorithms and many of the key both
engineering learnings that we took away
from
the how ingress operated as well as
product lessons that we took away
greatly informed how we implemented
Pokemon go so you mentioned sort of you
modernized stuff it I believe you using
communities behind the scenes rather
than the NAP engine yes what what sort
of drove that decision so App Engine
came from a different era of Google's
cloud services where things ran it in a
sandbox and it made it App Engine as a
product is actually quite good for
getting something out the door really
really quickly not having to worry about
you know huh whether your front ends
will scale not worth having to worry
about exactly you know what you're
you're you know we'll having full
control of your server loo-loo it's kind
of a plug and play for web services and
and so we initially implemented ingress
on that because that was what Google had
available you know five years back or so
and it worked quite well for us to begin
to understand you know how does running
a game where everybody in the world
actually has to share a single
consistent view of that world what kind
of technical trade-offs do you need to
make in order to make that happen in
your real time I'm delivered through the
latency of a mobile connection so App
Engine was great for the time that
ingress was launched now as we moved on
to Pokemon go we wanted to modernize our
architecture a bit and the major
difference between kubernetes and and
App Engine is that kubernetes gives you
something that's much closer to a raw
machine in a sense right you can run
your own I mean you can literally
literally run Java main and startup you
know your own your your own server there
and taking about network traffic and
configure it configure it to your liking
in fact you know we spun out of Google
how many of us are Google engineers and
kubernetes actually resembles very very
strongly the kind of internal
infrastructure that we were used to as
Google engineers of the ability to
define services that ran very close to
bare metal I had had all the flexibility
of being able to interact very closely
with the operating system and and and
the network stack but still was
abstracted enough away from the bare
metal such that we could rapidly scale
the
number of instances if necessary so what
kubernetes have eventually and Google
container engine gave us was all that
flexibility of scaling and deployment
that App Engine did plus much more
technical flexibility for us to define
our own our own binaries cool so keeping
on the topic of your your stack
you mentioned Java main which can I made
me sad because I was wondering if
[ __ ] [ __ ] was actually raining go in
any piece of it could you tell us is
everything written in Java what
languages are using so the server stack
is is as more or less Java and you know
as form of Google engineers and you know
being part of it the industry standard
Java really I think was the right
decision for us to make it allowed us to
iterate very very quickly on gameplay
concepts as well as bring in existing
code that we we had from ingress and
poured it over from App Engine to to
container engine um since Java was one
of the supported languages on on App
Engine so the other thing that Java
allowed us to do was because it was it's
an industry standard language which
allowed us to bring the best and
brightest of server engineers who wanted
to work on a product look like Pokemon
go into the Attic cool so one of the
things that kind of surprised me was I
saw that you were using datastore and at
the same time you have the biggest
kubernetes cluster in the world or at
least when we announced it it was the
biggest one as far as we are aware so I
was wondering I mean you definitely had
space to run the database on the
kubernetes cluster since it's so big why
didn't you do it why did you go with
datastore so there's some prior
experience that we had with datastore
but that was not determinative so
datastore was pretty much our only
option for ingress because we because
again App Engine is a squid framework
which allows you to allows you to not
have to worry about implementing a
database doesn't make you worry about
you know standing above your own web
server late binary etc but the price
that you pay is that you know you have
to go with the chosen storage technology
what's in that
case was datastore now that being said
datastore was wasn't
isn't is an awesome technology and
that's why we actually when we made the
transition from App Engine to container
engine we evaluated a variety of
different options you know being being
able to stand up or all um you know
relational database or using some other
cloud-based know what skills provider
was definitely other options that we
looked at well we kept coming back to
datastore and the the reason that we
stuck with datastore was because it
scales almost indefinitely from doing
individual development as an individual
developer on a test instance all the way
up to games at the scale Pokemon go
right and it scales seamlessly right you
don't need to do any configuration
changes at least on our side on the
developer side we didn't need to do any
configuration changes we didn't need to
do any kind of futzing with routing or
fussing with scaling the data base
backends or anything right all we had to
do was program against a set of
transactional api's and what we got in
return was multi entity transactions
that were consistent and distributed
that we didn't have to worry about
making sure were you know backed up were
replicated and advanced indexing
capabilities which go to which we use at
both the heart of both ingress and
Pokemon go and so you know after taking
a look at a lot of options right you
know maybe using like I started my SQL
instance or using a different you know
third-party Noah skill provider and we
really thought that datastore had the
most advanced combination of the scale
of the multi entity transactions for an
OS code datastore as well as advanced
indexing capabilities and ease of use
and maintenance that were just
unparalleled and frankly were a key part
of our success excellent oh that's super
cool so I know we've talked about G K in
datastore those the only products you're
using a you're able to talk about
anything else that you've used it's on
Google cloud platform or across Google
yes absolutely so one of the benefits of
having worked in Google and being formal
cool engineers is that we've actually
seen the progression of tools that
Google created for its own internal
internal engineering
progressively propagated out as Google
cloud platform products and one of the
ones I really want to highlight is
Google cloud BigTable you know we loved
working with BigTable as engineers
within Google it was it's a key part of
many many many Google systems and its
debut as an external service is for a
completely different use case student
over there for data store right data
store we use for you know transactions
whereas BigTable is more for bulk
storage and both data processing and
it's been an incredible product to
actually have on the outside and I hope
that Google continues to push more
important that's awesome internal tools
that uh we we love this engineer in
Google out to the cloud platform yeah we
can configure no no deny but yes I think
that that's but there's more coming yeah
awesome okay cool so it's probably sick
way actually quite nicely to you talked
about how it was datastore you didn't
have to do any changes to handle the
amount of throughput that was coming
through it was a very subtle way that
was quite I know that's quite cute so
but I know we have we've announced the
cluster reliability engineering team of
CRE team and they basically started
interacting with you as a customer how
is that experience like how did that go
what was what was that that I like so I
think here is actually a good time to go
through the whole story of the launch
because it's it's directly relevant to
how how how are that interaction was so
so helpful so we did our homework before
we launched Pokemon go I swear we did
right we we've had and we looked at the
launches for other mobile games talk to
your mobile games right once with
established IPS ones that were you know
sequels of like really popular games in
the past past couple years and we looked
at you know from publicly available
business intelligence right what what
the number of well what the growth
curves would look like what the number
of users that they would have would
would look like and we use those numbers
and our experience on ingress to
extrapolate from kind of the product
driven numbers like no monthly and daily
active users to what we thought would be
the load on our servers and on cloud
datastore
any given time and the cloud datastore
team leading up to our launch was great
they were constantly you know in touch
with us like helping us with upgrades to
the api's or you know fixes for you know
things that we didn't understand or when
we encounter them and they also asked
you know quite reasonably so what do you
think your capacity for launch will be
so we extrapolate from all those numbers
to what we thought was a reasonable
number right and then we multiply the
reasonable number by like five times and
said this is ludicrous nobody will ever
now ever go like five times bigger than
like anything else that's out there and
we'll ask the other sort of center that
as that aside for us so we launched the
game on the evening of July 5th so July
4th is of course a holiday the United
States we were lucky enough to actually
get everything squared away before the
holiday weekend and so I had everybody
go and have you know barbecues and watch
fireworks with it with their families we
came in rearing on July 5th ready to to
launch and the way that we we were going
to launch was that we started out with
Australia New Zealand
these markets that we could we could
watch that were in another time zone and
that we could we could we could see
through the evening as to how they
progressed before we moved on to more
populated areas of the world like the
United States and what ended up
happening was we immediately like it
looks like a star delta function spike
right like the immediately blew past the
you know the the 1x number that you know
the kind of baseline estimate for the
whole world that we thought we were
gonna write just in Australian New
Zealand and we were well on our way to
that ludicrous 5 X number by uh just
from just from Australia New Zealand
mind you are fairly new zealand we
expected to you know from from other
product launches of other other business
intelligence in the mobile market to be
you know single digit percentages that
most of the entire worldwide active user
base and this is at this point that we
called for our friends at Google and
said well you know those estimates that
we gave you those great ah we might need
to go a little bit higher
right haha and it turned out that over
the course of the next next few weeks as
we launched across all of the first the
United States the day after Australia
New Zealand and then progressively
around the rest of the world now we
ended up eventually needing something on
order of 50 times the initial capacity
estimates that we gave to cloud
datastore just a little bit so just a
little bit so that team was instrumental
in working with us to make sure that
that could happen I know I know that
pulling that off you know basically
within two weeks between you know our
initial launches to to launch in Japan
and and further on into the rest of the
month throughout Southeast Asia and
Latin America pulling that off required
a lot of a lot of work on the Google
side you know I don't think that they'd
ever seen anything of this magnitude
come through a single single customer
service and so I know that they did a
lot of work to rearrange for internal
resources and move things around in
their data centers to make sure that
they could support us all along the way
and you know during all of that we we
didn't have to like I said we didn't
have to change anything in our IPAs
right we didn't have to reconfigure you
know any kind of routing system or we
didn't have to you know change the type
of transactions we just kept on plugging
on doing what we were doing you know
fixing our bugs and fixing out you know
fixing out anything that we had in our
own servers that we had had to work out
to get the scale and the data store team
did did everything they could to support
us and so one of the things I'm really
proud of is that in fact I think that
the separation was actually full-on
complete Google engineers never took a
look into our code base we never invited
them to they never needed to write the
the layer of the API abstraction was was
complete and perfect right and I'm very
proud of of how we eventually ended up
scaling I know the first few days it was
obviously a little little difficult to
get to the servers but it turns out that
our fundamental technical architecture
was sound and what our scaling bugs were
were the kinds of things that you
normally run across as you scale up any
web service right
so a typical typical debugging loop
looks like to us like okay well let's
take us take a dump of all the stack
traces that were running in this in the
server right now
and oh like maybe 75% of them are caught
up on some silly mutex somewhere so you
go and you know you do a four line code
change to fix the mutex and then like
throughput shoots up on the server and
then you look for the next model neck
right these are things that are very
very routine for for people who deploy
what services at scale the only
difference between them and us is that
we had to do so on the back of a
rocketship you know I think other folks
get a little bit of a growth curve yeah
I have an article right now next to me
saying that after day to you um you
basically reach the daily users of
Twitter which is crazy like like the
amount of usage that you got so fast and
scaling that fast without like having
having to rewrite all your code and
pretty sure that if I have any of my
demos I have to scale them that much to
write the whole thing so that it's
pretty amazing well yeah I can't talk
about daily users in particular
unfortunately but obviously huh
you know if I made one of the other key
points of of the way that we scaled I'm
very very proud of is that these aren't
just isolated users working in their own
instance right I think we'll get to the
key of why this is so important later
but ultimately Pokemon go is a single
consistent world for everybody who plays
on it right if somebody Monday
methylates a polka stop and puts a lure
on their right everybody within you know
about kilometer has to see those petals
dropping from the polka stop right if a
set of you know a few dozen people are
in the same park together and there's a
swirl on one end of the park and they're
all within range of it they all have to
be able to see that squirtle at the same
time maintaining a consistent world
state means that we have a variety of
not just n scaling problems but N
squared like scaling problems right I'm
very proud that not only our algorithms
but Google Cloud Google's cloud platform
we're able to accommodate those
algorithms to scale in such a fashion
which i think is a real
non-trivial feat of engineering and it
is entirely empowered and by the fact
that we were running on container engine
and datastore and were able to basically
turn the knobs as necessary
with our binaries on those platforms in
order to to make the N squared scaling
work excellent I'm sure I'm gonna get
deflected but I feel like I should ask
anyway so what can we expect for the
future of Pokemon go unfortunately I
can't talk about any particular future
product launches but we are working very
very heavily on really a set of features
that frankly as a player I'm I'm
insanely excited about and will say that
ingress is about four years old and
during that time we have improved it
substantially I think that's response to
the game actually we're not there at
launch right so things like the ingress
mission system or the regionals scoring
system or player profile and badges all
this stuff was not there when we
initially launched ingress and we are
committed to these games for years
because we know from ingress we know
that people actually play them for years
and so I'm very very excited to follow
some similar trajectory on Pokemon go to
continue to support and build off major
features in this game and really bring a
lot more joy to people just as as time
goes on so you've obviously got a
history of building sort of mobile
location-based experiences and is there
plans to expand upon that more products
that sort of thing
absolutely so one of the great things
about moving to container engine was
that we took that we took the
opportunity while we did so to also
separate our game logic from what I
would call our core geospatial and query
logic right the core geospatial and
query logic and the way that we interact
with Google's cloud platforms are
suddenly a graded into a separate code
base literally we run to leap O's a
platform repo and then I get a game
specifically both so interesting we very
much want to make sure that the the set
of the way that we interact with the
cloud platform is nicely encapsulated so
that we can very quickly scale out our
own internal teams to try a variety of
really interesting new product ideas and
we really believe that this is a
genre an entire genre of games that
actually his problem is the future of
what mobile and AR gaming is gonna look
like and there are a lot of great ideas
out there and in order for us to be able
to rapidly iterate and try to winnow
them down into our next product we
absolutely need to be able to abstract
away the way that we interact with some
technologies and so in the creation of
Pokemon go we we are already took on on
the vast majority the work necessary to
do so and I'm really excited to to see
what we want to come up with next so in
a more personal note I know that for me
Pokemon go it actually changed a little
bit the way they'd like I would take the
bus less often because you know when the
latter the bus goes to five second
really cuts of Pokemon that easy so I
could walk a little bit more what about
you is there like I'm curious about you
since you lived it from the inside what
but what did Pokemon go change in your
life yeah so I will say on a personal
note my uh my father plays this game
religiously right and he's actually a
level 31 trainer which is amazing to me
because you know he hardly ever played
the video games ever in the past and
this is incredibly gratifying for me
personally because you know for the last
I'd say dozen or so years he's been he's
been managing his his blood sugar intake
because because of adult onset diabetes
and this game has gone him out walking
daily exploring his uh his neighborhood
keeping up his exercise and his godness
blood sugar tippy as rock solid in
stable as as ever I mean it's it's
incredible to be able to have that kind
of a kind of effect and if you think
about you know that's that's my father
of course like that that's incredibly
near and dear personal personal to me
but it's an incredibly gratifying as an
engineer to realize that there must be
millions of people like him out there
who are playing this game who are
improving their health who are finding
out finding out more about the
communities all because of code that not
only that we wrote but that Google's
cloud platform and powers right
ultimately Google make
these services available is a paradigm
shift in the way that single consistent
world gaming can actually be engineered
and can actually be deployed and
delivered to them with two mobile phones
and it's amazing to think that we have
we live in an era where we can actually
you know drive substantial changes in in
personal behavior for the better based
on on you know what people might think
of us dry technological concepts like
container emption
when in fact it's actually quite
exciting excellent that makes it makes a
lot of sense in that I can totally see
why that that is very exciting I
understand so we are running out of time
unfortunately I mean we could talk for
hours is there anything we haven't
touched on or something you want to
mention I know 90 is hiring I do want to
talk about that like what can we wrap up
with here yeah absolutely
not toukas hiring I think we really have
a lot of really great positions open not
only if you have experience in large
scales server server architecture I'm
both in you know see sharpen and and
Java but also on the mobile clients and
and device side know you asked earlier
about what languages we programmer in we
are also programming in unity and
c-sharp because ultimately we have a
mobile client that's beautiful that's
performant and that requires a lot of
not only unity code but also mobile
native code i'mso C++ Java Objective C
in order to make happen I also want to
plug one other bit of where we're going
as a company because I think every part
of the company would will feed into this
so one of the things that we've invested
a lot into in the past as part of
Pokemon go is the Pokemon go Plus which
is this device that you can actually
wear and that will play help you play
the game alongside you so that you can
actually have an experience playing the
game that doesn't involve your mobile
phone it can be a hands-off experience
at while you're still exploring the
world and and playing the game
simultaneously we really think that you
know even though the pokemon gold plus
is right now you know just a vibrating
button with some lights that it is a
harbinger of what hardware is going to
look like when in the future and you can
see you know from our you know very
first concept of trailers for this game
that we really really believe that
there's going to be from all of these
augmented reality hardware products that
people are trying out right now right
things like things like microsoft
hololens or or gules tango all these
different technologies that people are
trying to put out there to overlay
things on top of the real world that
there will be mobile technology that
integrates seamlessly integrates the the
real world
with a virtual one and we are very
excited to be at the forefront of that I
think we really demonstrated that
augmented reality technology is not
solely about the hardware experience
although we are very excited about
integrating those Hardware experiences
as they come online but we really
believe that augmented reality is just
as much about being able to have a
shared state with all the people around
you so that all of everybody who
participates in this reality really
believes that at a fundamental
fundamental level you know there's
something really magical about the idea
that you know when 10 people open up
their mobile phones and see a charizard
further down the block together right
that they all orient that in their mind
and they all believe that together right
and we really believe that shared social
experience is actually as much a part of
augmented reality as the the hardware
experiences will well be and at its core
those those social experiences are an N
squared problem that can only be solved
by operating on a platform of Google
Cloud excellent well ed thank you so
much for joining today that was
fascinating and I think our listeners
are going to really appreciate it thank
you very much for the opportunity I
really appreciate that chance to talk to
your listeners and I hope that they they
get something out of this as well
yeah and hopefully you said that you
could not share any of your future plans
but hopefully we'll have you back once
all of those secret future plans are
public very thank you so thanks again ed
for such an interesting interview there
is so much knowledge and I really feel
like these episodes could have been like
one hour along no forum like yeah there
was so much to say we had to stop it but
hopefully he'll be back soon
oh no
hopefully hopefully but yeah I I hope
you enjoyed the you enjoyed the
interview let us know if you have any
extra questions so we can ask them
directly if you want to but it's time to
go with the question of the week cool so
the question of the week we talked about
around encryption and data encryption of
data at rest the idea being so say I
have these keys right so I have these
encryption keys that I want to use for
encrypting my data at rest yeah I know
Google encrypts data at rest generally
but I want to use Marion keys how can I
do that yeah so that is actually
something that happens often is
sometimes some companies will have they
need to have their own keys yeah and
they need to be able to access them if
you're using Google Cloud storage
by default it will be encrypted but you
don't have the choice of this is a key I
want to use yeah another the same for
discs as well like so yeah it's like
it's actually basically for every data
store the rest is actually encrypted so
that is pretty cool
so now what we have is there's two
options either you manage completely
your keys and and that is hard because
you know is like security is hard your
keys are kind of an important thing to
keep I kept on losing my keys like my
house keys all the time but encryption
keys you know drama yeah and you can't
just like keep your encryption keys in a
bowl yeah it doesn't it doesn't yeah
that's what I do and I still lose them
but anyway the cool thing is that we
actually announced recently a new
service which is called Google Cloud key
management service and what it allows
you is to have your own keys that then
you can use for the encryption at rest
of your data and Google cloud platform
but also you're the one managing them
you can create them you can rotate them
you can delete them if you need to and
something that I really like is that
they're also this service is linked
directly to iam which makes it really
easy to manage who has access to what
keys and also it is also linked to other
login which means that you not only can
control who acts as what but you can
also see who did access what
which is something that internally at
Google we use and we know that many
other companies need to use so it's very
nice to have cool so actually that's a
really interesting point so I might be I
definitely have to have my own keys and
I have to manage to myself because of
some requirement or some sort of order
thing but maybe my requirements are more
just like oh you need to make sure you
rotate them this often there's nothing
like that in which case I could come to
Google cloud use the key management
service have them manage that and make
that really easy for me yeah basically
it's we understand that some people some
companies have very strict requirements
and that means that they will need to
manage them themselves and that is cool
but most of the time the manage the
requirements that their and I have will
be met already by Google Google Cloud
key management service and it makes
things just easier totally fair enough
all right cool well I think that wraps
up our episode though but I know you're
about to do some crazy travel I'm gonna
tell us where you're gonna be and what
you're up to
so by the time this episode comes on
online I will be somewhere in Italy and
gonna be in Florence speaking at goal at
dot IO after that I will go to Barcelona
hopefully speak at the Barcelona go meet
up after that aha
Brussels for Fossum so if you're gonna
be around enforce them
there's gonna be a go dev room go there
come say hi it's gonna be lots of fun
and after that off to India for gough
recur in India in Pune I'm almost sure
and mispronouncing it but I'm gonna keep
on saying it Pune till someone says no
it's actually pew or something I don't
know I have no idea what about you are
you travelling around I am staying in
San Francisco but still just as busy
will be here in San Francisco we're
hosting a global Game Jam location at
our Launchpad space sounds fun hi you
can sign up for that we still have some
room available then it's basically all
just run up until the game developer
conference here in San Francisco I'm
taking part in the game developer day
I'm gonna do a lot and talk there for
the Google game developer day for that
we have a sponsored session where I'm
gonna be talking about hosting basically
unity servers and site containers and
how to do that in the cloud and nice
floor so we talking about
stuff there's a bunch of stuff going on
at GDC even more I can talk about and
then finally yeah next is coming up
after that I know you like there as well
so next it's gonna be pretty awesome we
will both be speaking about different
topics and on top of that we might be
doing something special with the podcast
yeah well we'll definitely have a
podcast space so we'll be there with the
podcast so definitely come up and say
hello we will absolutely be there cloud
next it's gonna be huge
yeah I'm I'm very I'm between excited
and scared I'm terrified but yeah lots
of fun lots of people and hopefully many
of you are gonna be visiting so let us
know if you're around it's always a
pleasure to meet you absolutely so I
think that this episode was long enough
to be the first episode of the year so
thank you all for listening to us
and talk to you mark and to you all next
week see you all next week
you
[Music]